george washington university law
professor jeffrey rosen first met
justice ginsburg in an elevator in 1991
when he was just
a young law clerk for the u.s court of
appeals
that brief encounter led to a nearly
30-year friendship
that included the justice officiating at
his wedding to his wife lauren
he is the author of the book
conversations with rbg
ruth bader ginsburg on life love
liberty and law he joins us now from
washington
jeffrey good morning good morning
what what do you remember from that very
first encounter with
rbg
well i remember i was incredibly
intimidated because she was coming down
from a workout routine
and she was completely silent so to
break the ice because i couldn't think
of anything else to say i said
what operas have you seen recently and
that was just the right question to ask
she just blossomed and she got really
enthusiastic and we started talking
about opera i didn't even know she was
an opera fan
and that began this lifelong friendship
which is one of the greatest blessings
and honors of my life
which was based on 30 years of
conversations about music
life and law opera not not a question
would come off the top of my head
can you tell us your thoughts on both
her life
and her passing
it's impossible to overstate the degree
to which she inspired everyone who spent
time with
her to be our best self the cu
the national constitution center which i
had just did an amazing tribute video to
her which
broadcast uh two nights ago and it's
astonishing to watch i hope you'll check
it out online
we assembled her favorite opera singers
and also special friends like gloria
steinem
kate mckinnon who plays her on saturday
night live jennifer lopez others who met
and admired her
and all of them talked about the same
fact that whenever you're not using
every moment of the day productively
focused on helping others and improving
society you think
what would rbg do and then you just
buckle down and get back
to work and it's just the most daunting
example of self-discipline and devotion
to the ideal of a more equal america
that any of us had has ever encountered
and as a result
we were honored to live in the presence
of one of the most influential changes
influential advocates for constitutional
change in american history she is a
figure of
historic proportions as chief justice
robert said
and it was such an honor to have the
blessings of knowing her
so much was covered in her life and your
book
tried to cover so many of those topics
and conversations that spanned decades
what did you want people to take away
from it
be your best self work on just using her
words
work on something larger than yourself
that can
improve society and help the less
fortunate be inspired by how much you
can
accomplish every day if you set aside
unproductive emotions
her mother told her this and she often
noted that
when you get caught up in anger jealousy
and fear you get distracted from
productive work
it's very hard and she did it better
than anyone else but just using every
moment of the day to be
your best self and to help others be
their best self and to improve society
it's just an inspiration for all of us
a professor in the last decade or so she
went from not just supreme court justice
to
to cultural icon rbg what what did she
make of that notoriety and how did it
change her
uh she was amused by it and it didn't
change her of course she didn't know who
uh the notorious b.i.g was her law
clerks had to
tell her basically and she was so
surprised when people would stop her on
the street and ask her to take selfies
remember she was a judge's judge she'd
really just been very
under the radar for even when she joined
the supreme court um there was nothing
compared to her current celebrity
but there was a big change in 2013 in
her
dissenting opinions and she started to
speak with great
force and power because she thought the
supreme court had changed and it was her
responsibility to speak for the voice of
liberalism and those
unbelievable dissenting opinions are so
inspiring would be great for
viewers to read them today to remind
them
of her liberal legacy well thank you
professor rosen for sharing at such a
difficult time and in the time of loss
we appreciate it